حسنًا ، ربما لا يكون من المفاجئ أن
يختار هاري وميغان استخدام خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي
كأحد أسباب
العنصرية الرهيبة التي وُضعت ضدهما ، فهما
يعتمدان على المؤرخين اليساريين المتطرفين
الذين يعتمدون على عناوين الأخبار المزيفة
من ولي الأمر ومن أي مكان آخر
وماذا ''  نقول حقًا أن 52 من
بلاد الأمير هاري عند الولادة هم
أشخاص عنصريون سيئون ، هذا كله يتعلق بالسياسة في
نهاية المطاف ، أليس هذا كل شيء عن
كسب المال على المدى القصير من خلال تشكيك
العائلة المالكة والمملكة المتحدة ومن
ثم العطاء على المدى الطويل  منصة سياسية يمكن
من خلالها أن تبدأ ميغان حياتها المهنية
في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية ، يجب أن أقول إنني أعتقد في
تصرفاتهم أن سلوكهم تجاه
عائلاتهم وكل شيء
أي شخص آخر ليسوا أقل من
[ __ ]